figueroa live bonjour on en direct ce
mardi matin pour suivre la situation en
ukraine je suis avec alexis faire chaque
adjoint paul actu du figaro jean vincent
bonjour alexis on va décrypter avec toi
avec vous bien sûr ces cartes réalisées
par le service infographie du figaro
rappelle que c'est un article vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site du figaro
tout au long de ce live vous n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions on essaiera t
répandant mieux possible on est sur
facebook sur youtube sur le site du
figaro on peut commencer par une
question un peu général justement
comment évolue la situation générale en
ukraine alors le point le plus seyant
c'est qu'en fait les lignes de front ne
bouge plus tellement depuis pas mal de
joueurs ont même maintenant depuis plus
d'une semaine donc il ya une forme de
stabilité de d'immeubles
d'immobilisation du conflit mais on va
le voir plus en détail ça veut pas dire
que c'est terminé en gros il ya trois
fronts nord est et sud au nord le pour
l'instant les combats sont arrêtés il ya
un enjeu très important elle est ce
qu'on va voir dans le combat ce et dans
le sud c'est un peu en attente si on
résumer à très grands traits on va
parler de la mort de kiev la capitale du
pays la capitale du pays qui pouvaient
tomber très rapidement et finalement qui
qui résistent parce que c'est très
compliqué finalement d'encercler kiev
attention ça pouvait tomber très
rapidement dans une logique aurait été
vraiment une logique de décapitation du
gouvernement de prise par surprise de la
delà de la capitale ce qu'ils nous ont
été un objectif russe au début ça nice
ça n'a pas été le cas ils sont entrés
dans une logique beaucoup plus classique
ils ont avancé progressivement des deux
côtés du nieppe renvoie le nihab qui
traverse la capitale donc ils sont des
deux côtés il avancé aux siens viennent
aussi de de l'est et c'est une avancée
progressive mais là encore il faut bien
mesurer le les ordres de grandeur kiev
c'est une capitale de 2 8 millions
d'habitants est en fait si vous voulez
simplement faire le siège de kiev vous
avez vous tiré un
un trade environ 150 km2 de périmètre
autour de la capitale et ça c'est juste
autour mais il faut prendre une bande de
terre donc rien que de faire le siège de
kiev ça demande énormément d'hommes ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que les
russes sont à la fois l'ouest mais ne
bougent plus trop alors des combats irp
in envoie sur la sur la carte mais la
situation est stabilisée et pareil de
l'autre côté ils sont arrivés au port de
la capitale il ya eu des combats à mort
varient des contre attaques ukrainienne
les russes n'ont pas avancé et
maintenant on assiste même d'après
certains experts un des fortifications
russe comme si ils entraînent une forme
de deux sièges de siège avec une
stabilité de l'offensive russe on a vu
ce matin qui avait même une une
contre-offensive
ukrainienne à macquarie fpt
dont donc voilà on est vraiment là pour
le coup à l'arrêt et aussi à laon pour
comprendre c'est qu'il faut énormément
d'hommes pas pour prendre simplement
pour encercler kiev et si on remonte
dans la carte la carte générale du du
conflit on voit qu'en fait au nord-est
du pays mais vraiment la frontière avec
la rue voilà il ya deux cherniff tout
honneur que vous voyez là ça ne va pas
trop sur notre carte mais en gros deux
shérifs n'est pas prise elle est
toujours du côté ukrainien elle était
encerclée en fait les encercler les les
ukrainiens font preuve d'une d'une
résistance absolument farouche et et du
coup ça fixe un très grand nombre de
soldats russes est donc tout simplement
ses soldats ne peuvent pas être déployés
pour la le siège de kef mais ces villes
sont quand même
en c1 en cercle et pas toutes mes acquis
l'idée c'est de faire des sièges on voit
aussi l'avis de
deux soumis la ville de kharkiv soumis
et quasiment encerclée kharkiv c'est la
deuxième ville d'ukraine paraissait
gigantesque fait un million et demi
d'habitants vous vous donner un ordre de
grandeur pareil
la précédente grande guerre de haute
intensité russe hormis la syrie c'est un
peu particulier mais c'était la guerre
de tchétchénie la deuxième est bien
lançons de la tchétchénie c'est un
million et demi d'habitants c'est autant
que la seule ville de kharkiv donc là ça
donne quand même un ordre de grandeur de
de cette opération militaire spéciale
comme on dit au kremlin qui en fait la
plus grande guerre menée par la russie
depuis 1945
si on redescend un peu il ya la vie dit
zoom et on voit ces forces russes qui
vont pouvoir redescendre en fait vers le
sud oui ça c'est très intéressant parce
qu'en fait depuis le début on avance
légal à la frontière de des combats
avant c'est très peu au niveau du nom
basse là on aurait pu croire qu'au
contraire c'est l'état un point très
saillant puisque les en 2014 c'est de là
qu'ils étaient partis les combats déjà
entre les rebelles pro russe soutenu par
le par moscou et l'armée ukrainienne
mais parce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il ya énormément de force ukrainienne
qui sont le long du dombass le nom bath
et donc les territoires séparatistes en
orange et donc voit battre les russes
n'ont pas attaqué de manière frontale au
début de l'invasion est en fait ce qu'il
essaye de fait non je pense qu'il faut
être plutôt que tu reprennes la carte
générale non pas que c'est très bon on
wye à peu près avoir ici on comprend à
peu près donc là c'est le don bassin
orange en fait ce qu'il ya c'est que les
russes possèdent
une stratégie de taille c'est à dire
qu'il passe à la fois par le nord depuis
le territoire russe et par le sud c'est
à dire par la percée qui vient de la
crimée si tu descends ben voilà la
crimée de nouveau orange donc la
péninsule de crimée haine qui a été
annexé par la russie en 2014 il ya
vraiment un phénomène d'encerclement du
dombass qui est en cours et de ce point
de vue là
la ville d'izu mme au nom de cette carte
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir elle est
essentielle parce que ça participe de
cette manoeuvre d'enveloppement et la
question c'est que vont faire les
troupes ukrainienne qui sont à ce niveau
là est ce que l fond comme à marioupol
la vie dont on va parler ensuite cirque
elles elles résident marioupol elles
tiennent le plus long plus le plus
longtemps possible où est ce qu'ils
essayent un certain moment de se replier
tant qu'il est encore temps c'est trop
tôt pour le dire mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment l'enjeu de ces prochains jours
prochaines semaines parce que c'est
quand même on parle de caen une fois le
temps médiatique n'est pas forcément le
temps militaire et on parle de combat de
de haute intensité il faut rappeler
aussi que je gueule que dans le donbass
les faits les forces ukrainienne était
bien préparé mais qu'il y avait une
ligne de front qui était petit pied des
plantes elle était très bien préparé
donc le tout le terrain était
minet il y avait enfin voilà le les
ukrainiens s'étaient fortifiée à cet
endroit là ce qui était logique il faut
pas oublier que les les ukrainiens ne
pensez pas imaginer forcément qui aurait
une attaque gruss y compris depuis le
depuis la biélorussie tout honneur parce
que jusqu'à il ya jusqu'à l'élection
contestée de loukachenko il ya un peu
plus d'un an il ya un an
l'idée que les russes il se déployait
depuis la biélorussie c'était une
hypothèse n'était pas une hypothèse
extrêmement crédible oui et on en
rappelle que le fait que la biélorussie
parce que le
d'avoir en allier la ville aussi
perméable admire poutine d'être très
proche de kef absolument c'est que si
vous devez aller depuis le territoire
russe jusqu'à kiev il ya un sacré nombre
de kilomètres on le voit c'est la percée
qui vient de deux soumis qui va depuis
l'est vers kiev quand vous passez par un
bilan aussi vous êtes à 150 km il vous
suffit de longer la ligne après il
suffit les combats sont extrêmement
violent mais mais c'était évidemment
tout l'enjeu de cette offensive vous
voyez la frontière qui est ici il ya
charles martel dans les commentaires
qu'on salue d'apprécier de mai d'après
jean serait en train de perdre cette
guerre et nous dit il faut être très
très prudent sur sûr surtout s'ils ont
aussi redit on le redit les experts
l'heureux 10 mais il faut le répéter
ya un
trop de paramètres et par définition il
ya un brouillard de la guerre qui fait
qu'on
il est vraiment hasardeux
de parler à lundi qu'elle allait
indicative dans un futur kiné qui n'est
pas extrêmement proches étaient bien
quelques jours près oui surtout avec t
on rappelle les moyens de communication
la russie qui ne communique quasiment
pas sur ce qui se passe quasiment pas un
terrain les ukrainiens communique
beaucoup mais des deux côtés c'est une
propagande de guerre c'est pas une
critique de dire ça c'est juste
classique en temps de guerre parce que
ça consiste à démoraliser adversaires et
à remobiliser ses propres troupes donc
il faut rester très très vigilant sur
tous ses biens informationnels qui
peuvent exister des deux côtés et
jardins accueilli il ya beaucoup de
morts parmi les forces russes quatre
généraux et un amiral serait mort on en
a parlé oui on s'est très frappant ce
week-end ses lecteurs il ya donc cinq
officiers généraux alors pour l'instant
c'est plutôt l'équivalent de généraux de
brigade donc c'est des petits officiers
généraux
mais malgré tout c'est très très notable
cinq officiers généraux ça peut vouloir
dire beaucoup de choses c'est que face
aux problèmes de communication de
commandement des russes il est probable
il est possible que les officiers
généraux qui n'arrivent pas à
commander depuis depuis l'arrière sont
obligés d'aller très proche du fonds et
puis ça montre aussi que les ukrainiens
arriva à taper les russes en profondeur
notamment avec les frappes de drones
nombreuses qu'on a convenu qu'on a vu
sur
réseaux sociaux oui on a vu les frappes
de drones ou turcs ont d'abord ailleurs
les tartes et b2 qui devient un peu le
larmes l'inde symbolique de ce conflit
les turcs ont fait une très bonne
affaire parce que ça devient le larmes
un peu miracle c'est faux de dire ça
tarde miracle mais une sorte d'armes
symbolique qu'on a vu dans beaucoup de
conflits en syrie en libye
ou au karabagh en entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie est aujourd'hui en ukraine
sachant que la plupart du temps ces
drones données plutôt une mauvaise image
en occident tu
sais pernaut gagnent là entre guillemets
en terme de com politique c'est plutôt
pas mal pour le président turc puisque
la d entre guillemets du côté des
gentils et ses saillies réussi à se
placer alors que effectivement en libye
ou dans le cas dans le conflit entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie ses ailes
sont visités souhaitait plus décriée
absolument et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce sont des drones c'est pas
des drones ultra technologique qui
coûtent une fortune comme les drones
américains ou que comme l'euro drones
que les européens sont en train
paisiblement de d'essayer de mettre en
service là c'est un drone de moyenne
altitude et qui ne coûte pas très cher
et c'est assez pragmatiques la part des
johnny avoir investi ce créneau on peut
parler de la suite d'alors on a parlé de
du dombass avant l'arrivée d'ado n'y est
comparé à une mario paul n'a rien eu
paul klee dans le donbass en fait qui
est dans la partie est vraiment là la
frontière entre le nom basque y était
toujours sous l'autorité kenyane et le
dombass séparatiste donc c'est un port
qui est sur la mer d'azov est vraiment
sur lui pour le coup on s'est tous les
ukrainiens le savait depuis 2014 les
russes essaierait de prendre ce port est
donc les défenses étaient extrêmement
importantes avec notamment déploiement
de la milice
ultranationaliste ukrainienne azoff
alors là en fait les les russes n'ont
pas tellement attaqué par l'est c'est à
dire par deux nièces par le grand ce qu
ils sont surtout remonté depuis la
crimée pour contrôler toute la côte de
la mer d'azov ils ont pris milito paul
notamment pu perdre y ans ils sont
arrivés à marioupol et là ils ont
encerclé la ville qui est une sorte de
deux chaudron et la ville est
complètement encerclée on en reparlera
ensuite il ya des couloirs humanitaires
avec plein de rapport de force parce
qu'un couloir humanitaire n'est pas
seulement une manie terre oui
malheureusement c'est aussi une arme
politique militaire et là aujourd'hui
les rues ce jeudi les russes mais aussi
les tchétchènes qui sont beaucoup
déployé 1 à marioupol est qui et qui
avancent donc il est très probable que
les russes prennent marioupol dans les
jours à venir dans les jours à venir
nous tenons une semaine voilà c'est si
le plus probable
80 % des logements qui ont donné qu'ils
ont été détruits selon wade selon les
ukrainiens d'ukrainiens ces normes
après en fait en réalité c'est peu
étonnant dans tout l'est les combats
urbains qu'on a vu en syrie en irak y
avait des destructions de lille qui
étaient
ces noms terrifiant donc ça c'est c'est
la réalité
de la guerre on peut imaginer que
quelque chose pareille arrive aussi à
kiev une fois que les forces russes sont
plus mobilisés autour de kef comme elles
l'ont fait avec marie-paule finale alors
on en n'est pas là pour les raisons
qu'on me dit on à moncef avant
d'encercler clefe qui est complètement
il se passera forcément et on parle pas
en semaine parle peut-être en moi
donc pour l'instant on n'en est pas là
et par ailleurs rasé kiev comme on
raserait grozny
revenir hanter de génie en 2000 ça
serait pas la même chose symboliquement
et ses teintes impact pour l'impact la
communauté internationale en tout cas qu
une fois ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
l'exclure complètement mais je n'aurais
pas la même portée
ont lâché alain martel qui nous dit que
petit et qui vont se rencontrer selon un
site qu'il qui je veux nous n'avons pas
ces informations là du coup je ne peux
pas juger mais voilà une nouvelle fois l
soyez très prudent avec ce qui se dit en
ligne
soyez très prudents sur les sources
soit il faut il faut lire des choses qui
sont vérifiées et je pense que cette
information pour le coup nous n'avons
absolument pas
nous ont pas une mariée au paul on peut
valider que deux de ces fameux couloir
humanitaire et tout à l'heure et c'est
que ces couloirs humanitaires qui
permettent aux civils de quitter la
ville et qui sont finalement une arme
pour jacqueline pour une fois que les
sites sont partis de pouvoir bombarder
en toute légitimité j'ai engagé dans ce
qu'il faut commencer par dire que des
couloirs humanitaires pour des raisons
humanitaires dans ces cas là c'est quand
même une excellente chose parce que
voilà sinon on parlerait pas en milliers
de santé nos milliers de morts civils et
des dizaines de milliers peut-être
donc ça c'est une bonne chose après il
faut comprendre et pour ça il faudra
porter à la guerre en syrie comment
les couloirs humanitaires de vie
deviennent une arme jeu politique et
militaire c'est à dire que vous
établissez un rapport de force entre les
deux adversaires vous négociez des
couloirs humanitaires
est en fait une fois que les civils
seront partis une partie d'entre eux
l'assaillant ne bombarde et ont dit non
mais écoutez il ya plus de civils ou ce
qu'on a entendu
en syrie il ya un très grand nombre de
fois ils l'aiment ou ailleurs c'est si
jamais il reste des civils c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas voulu partir
et donc du coup ce sont des terroristes
ou là c'est pas l'expression de
terrorisme ce serait l'expression d'un
nationalisme
donc voilà ça devient un enjeu politique
militaire mais faut pas oublier que
c'est avant tout un enjeu manie terre et
par ailleurs on voit
énormément de d'informations
contradictoires entre ce que disent les
ukrainiens et les russes parce que les
ukrainiens disent que les russes
empêchent les civils de partir
et les russes disent l'inversé disent
que les ukrainiens
black bloc et empêchent les civils de
partir parce que grosso modo si jamais
il ya plus de civils il est plus facile
pour les russes de récupérer la ville a
donc cédé des débats interminables
qu'on entendait déjà en syrie et
dans cette guerre de l'information c'est
très difficile de savoir ce qu'il en est
vraiment
une si marie paule tombe dans l'est dans
les prochains jours on voudrait à ce que
dès les forces qui sont stationnés se
déplace vers d'autres tant là dit tout à
l'heure par exemple dans le donbass et
qui remonte en fait vers le sud alors
c'est là où il ya effectivement en fait
l'éloge les russes sont dans une
logique ou une invasion massive sur tous
les fronts à la fois n'est plus possible
en raison d'un manque de dom 2 est donc
en fait il faut qu'il gagne en un
endroit
pour ensuite avoir de nouveau des forces
disponibles pour alain autres et donc là
effectivement il est probable que si
mario peut le tourner dans les prochains
jours ils pourront redéployer les
troupes qui était fixé à marioupol alors
est ce qu'ils les redéploieront au nord
pour la taille du dombass vont parler où
est-ce qu'ils vont essayer de reprendre
leur offensive vers
l'ouest de l'ukraine au delà de dunières
et là c'est une autre possibilité parce
que finalement cette grande zone là en
rouge sur la carte c'est là que les
russes sont le plus avancé et le plus
rapidement au début de l'invasion
rebelles juste en termes de calendrier
que là on est pas moins à un amant après
un mois après quelques jours près on est
un mois de début de l'invasion et les
rues ça va avancer relativement
rapidement à la fois un peu vers le nord
jusqu'à la centrale nucléaire de
denner roda et puis vers le sud il est
épris personne j'ai ensuite il s'était
approché ni qualif est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ils ont aussi
avancé rapidement
parce qu'il y avait moins de défense
ukrainienne à cet endroit là et sauf que
la plus plus la ligne de front s'est en
plus il faut distendre les les forces
russes il faut contrôler des villes
aussi contrôler les villes notamment
médithau paul personne n'a vu qu'il ya
des manifestations
pacifiques
pour l'instant on n'assiste pas trop à
de la
guérilla de la part des ukrainiens dans
les territoires contrôlés par les russes
tout cas ça n'apparaît pas comme un
phénomène pour été observées qui serait
massif pour l'instant c'est vraiment des
manifs dont il est difficile de mesurer
l'ampleur parce que mine de rien en
territoire qu'ils contrôlent ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on a à carson a mito paul
donc bref les lire les russes n'ont pas
un nombre d'hommes infinie est donc là
ils ont dû stopper leur offensive il ya
même eu des contre attaques ukrainienne
efficace amic michaelis donc vraiment
halal ouest donc après 6 annonce dans le
donbass à marioupol et qui récupère des
forces et ce qu'ils pousseront et là
c'est la crainte depuis le début de
l'invasion c'est qu'ils aient jusqu'à au
dessin qu est la troisième ville du pays
qui est une ville historique de la
russie qui est un grand port de la mer
noire
c'est par là que transitent le blé
notamment qui récupère finalement est
donc là il indique aux progrès
l'intégralité de la rive ukrainienne de
la mer noire qui devrait deviendrai un
la grue cela que turco turcot russe
mais pour l'instant c'est parce qu'il
peut aussi remonter vers le nord on voit
la ville de gnat pro
et en fait visiblement ils essayent
aussi d'attaquer deniers pro à la fois
par l'ouest et par l'est on voit qu'ils
remontent par kryviy rih
donc là on est sur la rive droite du
nieppe et en même temps il remonte vers
après devient donc l'autre rive du nil
et ça converge vers niamey et là on voit
bien qu'ils pourraient étant leur
logique de l'ena une nouvelle de taille
les russes appellent ça des chaudrons
ce qu'ils encerclent de manière
concentrée que les forces ukrainienne
mais assez lentement
c'est pas une blitzkrieg un blitzkrieg à
la demande c'est plein de petites poches
qui se constitue et les ukrainiens
seraient
concède donc voilà ça là c'est la
dynamique de des prochains jours et il
faut l'avoir à l'esprit parce que quand
on regarde la carte un jour après
l'autre on se dit bah ça évolue
finalement très peu donc donc à un
enlisement
l'enlisement demeure un risque
pour les russes
il ya un autre risque pour les
ukrainiens c'est que par un effet domino
avec toutes ces petites poches ya un
effondrement brutal défense d'ukrainiens
et ça on l'a vu ça même été mentionnée
par le chef d'état major des armées
françaises le général burkhardt cas dans
une lettre aux militaires français a
écrit que c'est de me demeurer l'une des
possibilités oui parce que si les forces
tombent les uns après les autres les
blés russes vont pouvoir se concentrer
sur des voyages sur - objectif est donc
concentré leurs forces absolument mais
malgré tout je pense que c'est quand
même là la conclusion après à moi c'est
que les russes n'ont pas les moyens non
pour renverser complètement les forces
du craignait et occuper les plus grandes
villes du pays en tout cas en tout cas à
court terme on pourra justement une
question de mathieu cours ben ali sur
sur facebook il me dit comment la russie
va gérer sur la durée maintenant qu'on
est plus sur 7 sur cette attaque éclair
finalement voilà c'est une fête il ya
plusieurs plans mais le plan humain est
vraiment le plus important depuis le
début on parle des deux cent mille
hommes ils sont engagés par les russes
dans l'invasion de l'ukraine audit de
son ami l'homme ça paraît énorme
en réalité c'est pas tant que ça pour
prendre un pays qui encore une fois est
plus grand que la france on superficie
avec 40 millions d'habitants et avec des
villes absolument gigantesque par
ailleurs si c'est une opération qui dure
et qui est très rapide non le temps
pourquoi pas mais là par ailleurs il
faut les hommes peuvent pas combattre en
permanence donc il faut les relever il
faut que les forces tourner se régénère
donc c'est un vrai enjeu pour les russes
d'autant qu'on sait c'est pas combien on
sait qu'il ya des pertes qui sont très
importantes donc à cet enjeu humain il
yal'enjeu matériel alors le jeu matériel
on a vu qu'il ya eu des les photos ça
tourne sollied sociaux il ya des
dizaines voire des centaines de blindés
de chats qui sont calcinés qui ont été
ciblés notamment par les armées
occidentales
fourni à l'ukraine l'ailé mais les
missiles à vonnas en particulier les
missiles stinger contre contre les îles
les hélicoptères et les avions ne tient
il ya une vraie attraction des moyens
matériels russes en plus de l'attrition
men il ya aussi une autre dimension
celle les munitions on sait que depuis
le début de l'invasion les russes n'ont
pas réussi à contrôler intégralement le
ciel ukrainien ce qui peut paraître
assez étonnant d'ailleurs et donc quand
même une aviation qui est assez solide
sur le papier bien plus importante que
l'aviation kényane à comparable mais
langage de manière extrêmement timide
non c'est pas parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à faire des manoeuvres interarmes
est-ce qu'ils ont peur
la d6 à tapas ne vient vous il ya plein
d'hypothèses sur la table méfiance est
de constater qu'ils emploient peut
relativement peu l'aviation l'aviation
même si c'est un peu plus qu'au début et
donc du coup il repose énormément pour
leurs frappes sur des tirs de missiles à
longue portée mais qui sont la plupart
du temps effectué depuis la terre
notamment 1000 russie mais aussi en
russie avec les batteries de missiles
iskander voir depuis la merde avec les
missiles calibre tirés depuis des
navires mais sauf que ces armes là qui
sont des armes de précision qui sont
extrêmement chères et des munitions
complexe la russie n'en a pas un stock
infinie les estimations c'est environ
2000 entre 1500 et 2000 or là d'après
les américains qu'ils en auraient tiré
1100 faut quand même mesuré que les
russes en un mois on va tirer la moitié
de leur stock de d'armes qui sont des
armes
quasiment stratégique c'est à deux pas
des armes de précision donc ça va être
un enjeu pour les russes
et pas qu à long terme à court ou moyen
terme effectivement on a 100 perdent
irene ce qui nous dit pourrait-on
imaginer un blocus sur les bateaux
allant vers la russie en mer noire et en
est en mer baltique est ce que c'est des
choses dont on n'a pas de discuter
encore alors un embargo c'est considérer
que mesure de de guerre donc une
nouvelle fois on serait qu belligérants
moi c'est toujours le risque c'est
savoir où est la ligne rouge à ne pas
dépasser là on a vu qu'un général
français mais il est sa rex le thé assez
étonnante parce qu'il est minoritaire va
dire dans le sérail militaire a dit ok
d'accord on peut pas
assurer le ciel ukrainien parce que ça
faudrait engager des avions est allé
taper des avions russes mais en revanche
on pourrait tirer des missiles de
croisière l'idée tomahawk contre des
positions d'artillerie russes par
exemple en ukraine
franchement j'ai du mal à croire que le
kremlin ne considère pas ça comme un
acte de kobe léger il nous ferait
franchir la ligne rouge donc c'est tout
un enjeu de savoir jusqu'où jusqu'où on
peut aller et de faire le plus possible
mais en restant sous le seuil c'est
typiquement ce qui est extrêmement
efficace et toutes ses armes
relativement
modeste en fait extrêmement efficace
comme les missiles portatifs qu'on leur
qu'on leur fournit on appelait blub dans
les commentaires qui dit pourquoi
conquérir toutes ces villes se
concentrer seulement sur kiev du point
de vue de russes et plusieurs raisons
déjà lundi kiev ça serait une bataille
de plusieurs semaines voire plus en
moins et donc les russes notamment ont
besoin absolument deux victoires
intermédiaire
notamment pour dire à leurs populations
on n'est pas en train de perdre la
guerre donc là pour l'instant il ne
contrôle qu'une grande ville une grande
il ya plein de petites villes qu'ils
contrôlent mais une grande ville en a
qu'une c'est vers kiev peut passer et
carson
ils ont absolument besoin là dans les
jouets dans les semaines qui viennent
d'arriver avec un bilan dix ans on
contrôle plus qu'une bande ville
sachant que mario paul pourrait tomber
mais maria colle à quel prix
marioupol zim
micola if we may par le dessin sylvie
jean mentha ça demandera des des
semaines donc ils ont besoin de
résultats on va dire intermédiaire oui
on rappelle l'aïe kiev 150 km quand même
pour pensez vous réussir une salle pour
des forces de armées qui effectivement
sont éparpillés un peu dans dans tout le
pays en ce moment il ya un point où
c'est pas continer est bloqué mais ont
des raisons de problèmes de popularité
en interne il ne veut pas engager ou
très peu le moins possible le comptage
en deux donc les soldats qui se battent
en ukraine
en grande majorité sont des contractuels
des soldats professionnels mais la
russie
n'a pas les moyens d'en
déployer autant qu'il le voudrait or en
revanche en face les ukrainiens ont
sonné la mobilisation générale donc en
termes de
nombre d'hommes
c'est pas tant que ça david contre
goliath il ya une note de la fondation
pour la recherche stratégique frs
qu'a publié une des premières analyses
militaires vraiment complète de la
situation qui est très intéressante sur
ce point là alors après c'est pas parce
que les ukrainiens ont potentiellement
des centaines et des centaines de
milliers d'hommes que tout ça est
coordonnée et que ça ça crée une arme
une armée en état de marche mais malgré
tout il ya cet enjeu là qu'il faut
vraiment avoir l'esprit on parlait tout
à l'heure de cette fameuse ligne rouge
la question 6 c'est jusqu'où les
européens pourront laisser faire la
lumière poutine on a parlé de l'usaj de
d'armes chimiques par exemple est ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui quelles sont les
lignes rouges ddd occidentaux face à al
arich les occidentaux l'ont dit ils ne
veulent pas d'une guerre ouverte contre
la russie donc sauf changement de
braquet soudain et qui ferait
on changerait de dimanche ont tiré mais
donc sauf changement de braquet soudain
on restera en dessous de cette ligne
rouge mais ce qui ce qui du coup limites
assez sérieusement les les capacités
l'intervention militaire des occidentaux
mais encore une fois sous le seuil ils
peuvent en faire déjà énormément
par exemple on voit que les ukrainiens
sont assez bons temps
communications communications militaires
pas sur la notion ils ont une
bonne vue générale du conflit et en
termes tactiques on le voit c'est très
efficace mais c'est aussi très bon
moment parce qu'il bénéficie du
renseignement occidental
alors qu'au contraire les russes on sent
un peu on se dit parfois qu'il avance un
peu à la vague vous n'hésitez pas bien
sûr à continuer à poser vos questions on
est encore ensemble dans quelques
minutes est-ce qu on est aujourd'hui on
peut le dire un point de bascule de ce
conflit un mois après le début est ce
qu'on est à un point de bascule et
pourquoi on en serait alors dans tous
les cas on est un point de bascule parce
qu'on se rend compte que là on en est
justement c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure une guerre qui ne sera pas une
prise de contrôle du pays en un mois et
dans une guerre plus longue donc là les
russes dans tous les quads dans tous les
cas doivent se dire comment on va faire
pour tenir dans la durée est enfin là
les parallèles et des négociations et du
coup ça revient poser une question
2 est ce qu on a atteint le point
culminant ou est-ce qu'on s'approche du
point culminant du conflit ça c'est une
notion qui vient de clausewitz c'est au
bout d'un moment tout attaquant
ne peut plus on a plus intérêt à
continuer d'avancer simplement parce que
vu la pression des forces il
il ne peut plus par oui et donc la
question c'est est-ce que de ce qu'ont
eu là une sorte de point d'équilibré
vers lequel on va ça veut pas dire que
c'est la fin de la guerre le point
culminant ce n'est pas forcément la peau
neuve la fin des guerres mais en
revanche est ce qu'on est de ce point de
vue là 1,1 point de bascule et qui
pourrait expliquer que les économies et
les russes commencent on le voit même
s'ils disent qu'ils n'ont pour l'instant
les négociations achoppent malgré tout
on voit du côté ukrainien encore
aujourd'hui qu'il ya des il ya des
sujets sur lesquels ils sont clairement
en train de travailler sérieusement la
question de la neutralité du désarmement
de l'ukraine mais ensuite il faudrait
garantir la sécurité de l'ukraine et
donc forcément pour ça avant le sens de
cogarantie qui donnera la foi de l'otan
et de la russie ce qui au passage
l'ayant était une proposition qui a été
faite par jacques chirac dès 2004
pour le statut l'ukraine dont il ya
cette question là il ya la question du
don basse et de la crue mais sur la sur
lesquels
kiev probablement sera obligé de reculer
soasta territoire de reculer alors après
qu'est-ce qu'on la diversification comme
on sait pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire
bon voilà
s'il s'agit de de démilitariser les
milices comme asaf et c'est là encore
été des négociations possibles mais en
tout cas on en arrive à un point
on continue de faire la guerre
mais y'a une une stabilité qui apparaît
et en même temps parallèle on fait des
négociants n'allant starter dans les
commentaires que j'ai demandé quand même
de rester polis c'est bien évidemment
avec nous qui vous dit que poutine va
réclamer tout l'est de l'ukraine c'est
une possibilité cirque encore une fois
il faut parler au conditionnel il ya
plusieurs scénarios possibles il ya le
scénario où la guerre
se prolonge et même s'accentue et où on
verrait apparaître la possibilité que ce
scénario de partitions de l'ukraine
devienne
un est l'un des buts de guerre possible
de la dir routine et d'ailleurs on n'en
sait rien c'est peut-être un but de
guerre depuis le départ de vanier opt-in
notre cas les négociations pour
l'instant ne porte pas sur ce scénario
c'est un scénario qui serait pour
l'instant inenvisageable du côté
occidental du côté de kiev mais on peut
imaginer que le que pour les russes le
nihab soit une forme de frontières et
puis qui récupère qu'il tente de
récupérer le sud de la russie mais
militairement pour l'instant ils n'en
sont pas là on a & m 92 qui nous dit est
ce que gouvernement ukrainien pourrait
partir vers l'ouest ou le sud ouest pour
continuer la liste la lutte ou même dans
un pays frontalier une fois de plus on
ne peut pas nous deviner ce qui sinon ne
peut pas être la seule chose qu'on peut
dire c'est que pour l'instant ce qui est
fait n'est pas en cercle et
donc la question dont on pensait qu'elle
se poserait assez rapidement il serait
le moment où le gouvernement vienne ce
qui serait obligé de partir par exemple
à vif dans l'extrême ouest de l'ukraine
pour l'instant cette question se pose
pas encore de manière
urgente à court terme et l'hypothèse où
il devrait partir en pologne encore
moins on à charles martel dans les
commentaires qui me dit que l'attentât
était lamentable c'est au niveau de son
armée les budgets ont été rognées alors
sans aller jusque là est ce qu'on peut
dire que il y avait une surévaluation de
dd des forces russes oui ça c'est très
probable
mais il faut pas être carré qui
caricaturait l'oncle sam a été une
grande réforme qui a été engagée à
partir de 2008 n'a fait un papier dans
le figaro sur cette question de la
réforme russe 2008
donc une grande réforme engagée en 2008
en fait après la guerre de géorgie qui a
été héroïque ce métier victorieux mais
en revanche ils sont rendus compte que
sur le terrain il y avait énormément de
problèmes étaient apparus au grand jour
et alors simplement ciblés on a pour le
dire de manière très rapide on a vu de
manière peut-être excessives les progrès
de certains armements 2.2 russes qui ont
été mises en avant par vladimir poutine
et qui aurait sous tendu une
modernisation impressionnante défense
arménien pays et on n'a pas vu qu en
dessous dans la grande masse de l'armée
russe là ça n'avait pas suivi et et que
là bas les russes ne sont pas des
difficultés énormes en terme logistique
en termes de communication qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à faire des manoeuvres
interarmées complexe et que du coup on a
tous les guillemets on voit toujours là
la vieille armée rouge qui n'est pas une
armée moderne au sens à la pointe de la
technologie occidentale du terrain le
sait cet article at on entendu à l'école
maternelle la grande réforme de l'armée
russe mise en échec soit champ de
bataille un article pour nos abonnés
nous on n'était pas bien sûr à vous
abonner au figaro pour avoir accès à ces
articles
on peut parler des différentes alors oui
je vois que dans le chat du fils héros
thomas qui s'occupe de la modération a
posté au si cet article merci beaucoup à
lui on peut parler d des négociations
justement des négociations qui ont
débuté depuis plusieurs semaines en
quasiment depuis le début de l'invasion
si on prend un peu de recul on le disait
ccc ccc négociations si on arrive à ce
point de bascule c'est le moment où ces
négociants sont les plus importantes qui
n'a absolument cesser le
les négociations dépend de la situation
militaire
et donc c'est vrai que c'est trop tôt
encore pour dire où est ce qu'on ira
mais en tout cas on voit les bases de la
négociation aujourd'hui elles
apparaissent clairement après ça ne
présage pas de l'avenir encore une fois
ce qui est intéressant quand même soit
négociations c'est qu'on entend de plus
en plus
à l'idée que israël que la turquie
servirait directement ou indirectement
de deux médiateurs et ça c'est
intéressant parce que historiquement
sylvain non ceux des zooms complètement
ça serait un conflit en europe
et la solution diplomatique serait à
trouver
mais hors d'eux
hors de l'europe sachant qu'on parle
même de la chine parce que le pays a
évidemment une influence considérable
sur la russie c'est la chine et on a vu
un responsable européen je veux pas dire
de bêtise peut être borel mais à
vérifier qui a même explicitement
demandé à ce que la chine serve de
médiateur alors on connaît la présence
chinoise qui
donc pour l'instant rien de tout cela ne
se voit mais néanmoins react le fait
d'en parler de le mentionner cela dit
quelque chose de notre de notre monde et
au delà la question est ce que la russie
a acté dans tous les cas une forme de
divorce avec l'occident est-ce qu'elle
va
s'isoler complètement
refermée derrière ses frontières avec le
complexe si dione à la rue c'est le
sidna sur le sentiment d'être assiégée
où est-ce que c'est pas un isolement
mais elle va essayer de se tourner vers
le reste du monde il y avait une analyse
d'un chercheur qui finalise des réseaux
sociaux et qui montrait que un chercheur
britannique qui montrait que la la la
guerre de l'information a
indubitablement été emportés par les
ukrainiens mais en occident et en chine
il a fait une analyse des messages sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui montraient
que le narrative russe
avec toutes les incohérences qui a
derrière mais dans anti colonialiste
anti impérialiste et c'est
avait une certaine portée en afrique et
en asie qui avait l'idée qu'il fallait
une sorte de
de respect des briques c'était les
puissances émergentes devait se soutenir
entre elles c'est très intéressant et ça
ça va être aussi une des questions
centrales de l'issue du conflit oui
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de la chine
alors j'ai juste faire un petit aparté
pour vous demander de dans le chat bien
évidemment vous pouvez continuer à poser
vos questions débattre entre vous tout
en restant poli bien évidemment sur la
chine on a parlé comme comme combat jean
serait l'allier numéro un de la russie
c'est beaucoup plus complexe et nuancé
que ça alors la chine est l'alliée de la
russie aujourd'hui ça ne fait pas de
doute
simplement la chine n'a pas forcément
vie pour une raison économique politique
diverse
de s'engager à ce point dans une guerre
qui n'est pas la sienne
et de perdre
du même coup les bénéfices qu'elle tire
de la relation qu'elle maintient avec en
vo l'occident notamment pour des raisons
économiques mais en revanche le fait que
la chine et la russie sont aujourd'hui
des alliés des alliés de plus en plus
stratégique est passée le mans tactique
c'est pas juste un rapprochement
occasionnels c'est une partage
probablement une même vision des
relations internationales c'est quelque
chose d'assez un fait majeur et
et puis son de ce qu'on voit là
aujourd'hui on en parlait tout à l'heure
dans l'est dans la partie négociations
entre la russie et l'ukraine il ya un
premier échange de prisonniers qui va
avoir lieu selon une agence de presse
russe est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
était qui était attendu au final
pour l'instant d'en parler assez peu
depuis le début du conflit
après si on compare encore une fois avec
la guerre russe en syrie c'est assez peu
étonnant parce que c'était apparu voilà
quelque chose de classique pendant ce
temps j'ai pas tellement de formation de
ceux dont
adamo rssi qui nous demandaient
commentaires alors on a peut-être
répondu un passé qui est à l'heure mais
pensez vous que l'occident serait réagir
en cas d' usage de l'armé nucléaire par
la russie pour terminer le le conflit
ont peut-être parler de cette arme
nucléaire qui est brandi qui a été
brandie qu'il était dont la numéro 10
n'a parlé à ses taux aussi dans ce
conflit bien qu'il ya plusieurs types
d'armes nucléaires qui pourraient être
utilisés je crois qu'il faut d'abord ne
pas se projeter déjà
après l'utilisation possible d'un
nucléaire par là aussi
ce qu'il ya de manière générale c'est
que ce à quoi on assiste
cl retour de l'utilisation surtout du
côté russe de la grammaire de la
dissuasion nucléaire
qui nous avait un peu échappé depuis
1991 donc là on se retrouve
finalement dans une quelque chose qu'on
a connue mais il ya assez longtemps
pendant la guerre froide mais entre les
premiers mots ont été échangés sur le
sujet entre les russes et les les
occidentaux
entre ces mots et l' usage de l'armé
atomique
il ya énormément de seuil
dans l'escaladé donc on en est pas
encore là
oui nouvelle phase et que pâques est ce
qu'on peut exclure mais on n'est pas un
peu un peu par définition ne peut jamais
l'exclure avec les dispositions sinon il
n'y a plus rien de dissuasif
mais voilà je pense qu'il ya une sorte
de réapprentissage
de cette grammaire de la dissuasion et
je pense que du côté occidental on se
rend compte que il faut pas seulement
que les dirigeants maîtrise cette
grammaire c'est absolument essentiel
sinon on court à la catastrophe
mais il faut aussi que les populations
soient relativement familière de
cette relation militaire étonnante de
dissuasion parce que sinon on en arrive
à une forme de de panique qui en plus en
l'occurrence à rallonge le kremlin quand
on a vu plein de deux déclarations sur
sur twitter dans les médias sur le super
missiles russes satan etc
on
se fait un peu peur de son missile n'est
pas encore en service
les russes ont une capacité de frappe
avec des missiles intercontinentaux une
capacité de seconde frappe avec des des
sous marins ça n'est pas nouveau c'est
une donnée très ancienne par ailleurs on
voit qu'ils ont envoyé un message aux
occidentaux en utilisant des missiles
hypersonique alors qu une capacité du
alsa qui peuvent emporter une charge
nucléaire mais la vie dont c'était de
charges conventionnelles
ça a servi officiellement on n'est même
pas la confirmation du fait qu'ils ont
vraiment été l'utiliser mais ça sert à
rien d'un point de vue tactique
d'utiliser missiles utile jal
hypersonique plutôt qu'un missile
iskander qui ont été attirés à à 800
unités depuis le début du conflit ça
envoie un message aux occidentaux ou
encore une fois il ya plein de marche
dans l'escaladé et il ya à côté de la
dissuasion nucléaire ni à la dissuasion
conventionnel
voilà après faut pas en faire trop sur
les armes magiques devenir poutine c'est
c'est eh oui ces médias de la com et
c'est normal c'est la voyons de la
promenade ces missiles hypersonique
finalement ne ne change pas grand chose
par rapport à des missiles qui ont été
en tout cas là en l'occurrence sur le
terrain
il n'apporte rien de plus que ce qu'on
aurait pu faire un un missile iskander
missile qui anime un missile
hypersonique fait simplement un missile
c'est une convention à messieurs qui va
plus de cinq fois la vitesse
du son
ont déjà la plupart des missiles
intercontinentaux mais depuis les années
70 sont hyper sonic est simplement
aujourd'hui on a des mets simplement ils
ont une trajectoire balistique très
prévisible est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les missiles personicx et
des missiles qui en plus ont des
trajectoires extrêmement
complexe ils sont manoeuvrable et donc
ils sont très difficilement intercepta
bhl est par ailleurs c'est des armes qui
sont pas des armes de dissuasion
nucléaire mais qui peuvent être des
armes
d'emplois et donc voilà c'est ça qui
change la donne mais il faut pas en
faire trop non plus très bien merci
beaucoup alexis l'autre d'avoir été
présent à haguenau merci à vous les
retards du figaro d'avoir été là pour
suivre tout tout tout tout tout ce
décryptage
merci aussi au service infographie du
filet rang pour pour tous ces cartes
qu'on vous a montré aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à eux qu'on a pu faire ce direct
merci à eux une nouvelle fois demain il
y aura un rendez vous puisque woods elin
qui s'exprimera devant le parlement
français c'est prévu un quart d'heure on
le suivra sur le site du figaro bien
évidemment et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur fear alive